доброго дня пустуни
журналісти доброго дня зробили крок в не для
дачі в полі ділок 11 ви і пня раз
починається основний етап ступнів
компанії до вищих початкових закладів
по заду сонячна закладеного тіні
та розплачується подача документів
конкурсний with beer ступні київ та
проведення в ступнях спробувати там де
б ні передачі не 11 ви пня подають
документи особливі вести єне компанія
типу передні що всі документи подаються
в електронному виглядаємо будь-які документи
та keys тусуються ступу на програми
бакалавра і ми хочемо і так вже за видами
це і що ті абітурієнти кипу чуваки
важко чистим і огляди з труби
можеш прийти у бутік і вийшли початковий
заходу та консультації не функції мда
допоможе по дати всі ці документи в
електронному у виглядає для того, щоб по
дати документи в електронному вигляді
мила пляма zara з труба тис на сайті
про svetak7
сага левин називається так і zc
електронний запит можна так рушниць
роботи crab house with a всім орфей вся
душа докладна інформацією на нашому
сайті міністерства про святі наукою а мені
хотілося від капелюха відомі ти псих протез
що 6 ви пня кабінет міністрів за
твердим апсиди державного замок лінія
ці психи державного замок смердить дасть
від неї оптимістичніше он з більш не
поспішай не за крима для мовляв кращого
спеціаліста а у 2016 роті тут
особи в уста не на берному у кращого
спеціаліста як-1 і ступа не вище його
почти прийому
чим розум уник цієї опції всім добрий
відомі що ми моєму за раз проблеми на
місцях з фінансуванням профі сильно
технічних початкових закладів
і як що на місцях трахатись ситуація
що буде менше на регіональний
замовлення тому що регіональний
замовлення з ви але бунти в тому
абсцес як ми довели до регіонів
бо що він і буде ви канонів так і
від повинна бути це може
вид криті можливості вступить і для 9
клас на київ з дубу вати про свиту
молодшого спеціаліста сам цьому більше
на кілька з міс нам у кращого
спеціаліста на 10 сотки
так уже про птср державної замовлення
адреса за рахунок з великими замовлення
на технічний та аграрний спеціальності я
кивнув він молоді ж йому фахівці так
їхнім тілам
на і шукай саблі треба помсти че
спеціальностей аки у сфері міністерства
оборони міністерства охорони здоров'я
також дорослі за про цигун і c пов'язано з
підйом і в нашої вкрай чинності
у нас показані казуального психу крайову
на підготовку викравши наука ви хто
наукова педагогічних кадрів передачі
ну а кіль кістки 245000
вусик злих задану форму та навчання
oriental але близько 217 тисяч
джину складається ситуація що
orient овну по логу по 10 сотки
tedx студентики витратити до вищих
початкових закладі
зможе на вчати себе за кожен бюджет
там у цілі дуст від нього оптимістично
інформація для наших абітурієнтів та для
них доступ
за конкурсом свята, що тонуть, і для нас
головна
головне завдання і тінисті їй у ступні
компанії що мета доступ бог
справедливий і уступ я хочу провернути і
найважливіше
готовий від ми будемо Ісус правою девіс
забезпечувати окрім того щоб він і
складу сонячний назвеш знайти його не
і далі проживатиму автоматизована
система rus подіумі державного за блискавка
без поспіху чарку ворог вивалиться
інтереси самого абітурієнта вин прибираючи
свої пріоритети ви знаєте що ви не
може по дати 15 заяв до
п'є її вищих заразу духовочку ви
чому може і туди ти 15 заяв проти
ті 15 заяв може but i
паданні док я ти спеціальностей у різанини
ви щен овчарні від води України також
абітурієнти будуть мати чоловіка висяк
щоб не ви значилося нас пріоритетом щодо
який спеціальності та потро порожній раб там
у вище у вищій навчальний заклад
ден і набирається ріпу видно кіль кисть
су гроші а ви там виловити крито групи
в ті та спеціальністю он і будуть з
прямого не систему і самої туди що так
соціальної всякої хмари могла на і ми
зрозуміємо ці зробимо у
початковому закладі і це дуже важливо для
щоб владні наприклад
навіть місця державного замок і жодні
виділ і не над технічною спеціальністю
довідки за вийшов через технічне та
спеціальностям крем
tu справедливість для нас польова так
вже тому, що я чистий на український храм
океан яких зірок
у спас гійом і я типу рудого я наш
окраїна повстання рук і досвід і вася фаза
системи та українські квіти за крим
відсилання кований крим і на піт
контрольної території цієї лінії
розмежування
і ті биті еблі рибних умовах по
підготовці тузом зайвого на закладеного
tenue ваня у ременя не стопу сни до
маякін спілкується в Україні там убиті з них
території малої 2 може зрости 1
можеш вивести складу ти пам'ятаєш не на
закладеного оцінювання для них будуть
рівними спеціально йдуть від кави сесії
легше води схилитися за зовнішні гази
лижного тіні вання ми не можете тупо
ти-то всіх вищих початкових заході
україни над міс як що он і мені
складу лізу зовнішнього на належному тіні
вання а вже два роки і ви навчитесь в
де-факто
в російську зі зграями про свити водний
може в ступа ти візьме шині вихино в
чайне за клади та для кримчан
у нас їй paris elec так їх 2 початі
вишок початкових за клодій в які з
перебувають у син та місцях України і там
вид крити їх вищих початкових закладок
центри крим україна
он і падають дацик центр про свиню
декларацію в yaki-da клару віч про свою
турботу про свиту виймає пласта
українську мову то історії України щоб
довести що ви не готові на в чат якщо
вид по видно в українських вищих
початкових закладок мету відкриваючи чоловіки
без вкладу tedx ступні та speed with по
видно так а брану і спеціальностей аж ніж
він його 3 адже ми чоловіки без ставків
навчання на першому курсі і так вже перес
класний вид по державну піцу
нову атестацію щоб ти українська
атестат так само з тусується дітей ви на
підконтрольних територій Донбас біля Алли
а он і зможе ступати і подавати через
так їх у кольорових центрі столітті називається
донбас україна у всіх евакуйованих
вищих початкових
за кладах donbass.ua так уже ти kikis
знаходиться на підконтрольній території
донецької та луганської області
ми поважаємо і шліци дуже важливо crockid
та й крейда для реінтеграції за тими своїми
територій в Україні відразу міну що можу
у вас їй багата технічних петанів
конкретних і уточнюючий і ви зможете їх
поставлять і чим і не за 1 год.
так що я піду також завищувати куль і і
носу , справа в тому, що право на вищого
святого на ньому вже буде і прив'язано
кількою дорозвідкою
роб ринку брати там ще на рожевий так
ринку проти спливає дуже багато
різьблені чорниці та фінансово економічна
ситуація та
тестовий збувається з економіки та україни
і цикл якобі навіть у нас правдивий
ніг брати штейн цю статтю розлучені
щоб усі
технічніше спеціальності буду за
вимогам повністю особливо викрав
вишлю якщо ти
а ось тут є шия одна проблема у нас
сьогодні пачино і розвивайся
високотехнологічний бізнес ідей
високотехнологічний бізнес
гаряча вчора у нас була така нарада з до
дитиною та технічних ваш тип початкових
закладі та представлені до ми
високотехнологічного бізнесу заявляючи що
і мені замість чаю викравши за адекватну
підготовку праворуч у тому, що мало
наприклад яким від аттики технічного
святого не хоче, щоб такі противники
значки добрі і на земному його щоб він
не так вже й у милий проти ти з людьми
і приємний вона позову
їж їх чаду готових ви міг до випускники
і зараз ми про в'язницю над новим і
стандартам і вишлю а святі кима осіб
євро hugo ти щось збила молодшого
спеціаліста на технічні напрямки
і на аграр не спеціальності тут ми
прибрали фарби спеціальностей які за раз
мають потребу на ринку брати я хочу на
волосся ти що мета рівний молодшого
фахівця цінний ревінь магістра обидва
бакалавра крем того шеннон миколи
миємо думати і на виріз аджики викрали
вступають усі уроку вийдуть на ринок
практик через п'ять-шість руки і ціл
означає що я що ми обидва ранній у
сіток та інноваційне зростання в підсумку
економіки і ви означив і пріоритет не
сфери для собак кластери економіки та
мати розвиватись україну ми по ви
почин від них ось у ватафо fifteen для
своїх кластерів вже сьогодні ще б око
копита не
а там першими втратив і рукою
можливість
пізніше у нас ситуація це як що е
конкурс за результатом та вступних з
таких для перших категорій цін c та
категорія дітей які nemours складу ти
зол нижчого на заборгованості його немає
через t
що сьогодні ми очевидно інших
проблем зі здоров'ям не можемо моїм пити
бутово ти забезпечать і адекватніше розумом
та проходження сонячну на за належного
оцінювання вже я така категорія дітей
іван і завжди я хочу прекрасний тому
що в деці за сук масової інформації
було написано всі ми у porsche та дали йому
живи з таким дітям заступатися за
вступаємо та випробувані цінний вигляд повидає
дієвості
битий для таких не могло бути
організовані зони шини заручниці не
я за їхнім станом здоров'я завжди вступав і
доступні моріс потім до таких категорій
накласти так вже биті з і ось і йдуть від
їх категорій належать до кову службу
вівці та яскраві демобілізований хоче з
дубу ти вийшла свиту і очевидно знаходять
життя зоні ато в an animal його туго тис
цю зоні шиньйони повинні оцінювати
крим того як ви дому у нас так вже й
квоти для дітей
закупівля ванної та території криму та
сьогодні перед у нас клей для всіх то
вступаючи за квота ми з вуликом гвинтом на
10500 ківі державного замовлення
а на донбасі у наших вищих початкових
закладок та keys знаходиться в донецьку та
луганську та області там і моєму квоту до
30 Адже сотні тому що ми розуміємо що
Тут і гра може прийти і най-най
тугіше ви значите але будуть і ти
dit is та непідконтрольних територій та
зон та розмежування там де була
організована нормального початкового
процесу
плечовому є важливий момент, що наша
система автоматичного раз у справі
танцює акрил джином що у польшу черву
запас підшивається
інтереси псих абітурієнту якима і
високий бал і за неї і які мають
чи прибирає вищий навчальний заклад
е1 тика вас вивести їй компанії що
поточна початкова зад владики пропан
затишний крадіжку я key issues with і
та їх прибирають абітурієнти факти чим своїм
вибором ван і голосу і цінних он з
може на брат і
за встановленими опціями на 25
сотки в пак і абітурієнти в цюріх для
набору
але це чоловіка зробити до того що
державні замок лінія довідки будда
сьогодні нам показують і я йду туди і
абітурієнти
найзлиденні і красиві начальники
зад води не секрет що для нас важливо його
щоб ми відривалися ціль не вище
навчальний заклад і тому що я keys
вийшли з вигляду з забезпечується якийсь
пензлем вийшли в початкових за plague of
пишуть ширку
великим і вищим і початковим і заходом
справа на видно в їхньому розмірі а сам
айтеми я кидають які знову свиту
і куди промивають під раб це абітурієнти
так так так я все до
до 20 5 вид сотки guide & yaki забирається
та вищі початкові заклад з високими
балами можеш забираються і заклад
піднятій уму планку державному замку
part-fcl прошу так випадково за раз
викликали опція hide р за блискавка на
ремені ми новому року для шкірного вищого
початкового закладу оліг що цар вищої
початковий заклад буду у браму і
shaquille keys абітурієнтів з високими
балами столітті його поставив і за
пріоритетний виберу там можемо
максимально більше 1000 до 25 сотки
berza мовляв вони я хочу сказати що цин
ми реалізуємо у
новий закон пробуєш його свиту тому що
повз і
меншого способу в норму вати ми народжую
вищих початкових за ікла та дати
кодексом та
підкріпить та tedx хто просив та гарніше та
кого прибирає абітурієнти ніш владні
дати чоловіка весь абітурієнтам
козацьким окей вищий навчальний заклад
фарбований я хочу за поважати і що ціни
означали, що, наприклад, всі абітурієнти
може вибрати економіку чиї права та
будуть сильно в чат з на економіці
чупров че правити тут на ліку ліміту
але і тримаючи на замовлення розбудив і
але за фахом їх вид повернутий від
їх стежкою травня сьогодні економіка в
україні наприклад я вже процес сьогодні
говорилося русло дихаючи на замовлення на
викрасти його кислий
у нас є 200 хворих і в різьблених 200 пар
нікоти кишки votre і малі максимальний
бал у різних областях України я цукор
майбутнього вражений залишалося за так їх
рейтинги в тому, що за раз напружуватися
результатом і восени смердять що знаєте
який середній а середній піт хіт
середньостатистичної по ряду мрії
київ далі львівська область харківська
область дніпропетровська область
alienation абсолютно об'єкта і не
передумав і тому що опціях великих
місцях за старріджа але дуже багато
спеціалізованих за плагін про святі
лики ви в чай
кути полону рис не предмети і нашим це
нас правді щоб ми мало гаварні
результат це змивання русі та україни та
за крима вигляд буваєте за 1 або пізно це
проект пов'язаний з витвором наполегливих
шкіл російськими цінами
тому що у нас душа турбу і що за
результатом через нього де ти стала моєю
в 10 разів ми ще шанс із класні
успішного тестувальня скалкою мною йому
ви c означали що гід із села не маяки
дитині доступу допишу і якщо ти vape
ременя не злити мис місця відразу мило і
все-таки гіти навчається у маленький
школі д 1 в 4 скарби та
та англійську мову та фізику та фізкультуру
через упор не школи наш пік літа кліпу
чітко ложку ламаючись знаходиться ягодою
боїшся думі себе проживання дитинки там
можна організувати анапчани від вечері на
адже душа маленькій школі на томі сидить
і старші школи травня до ось цієї сова
коріння школи та й кваліфікації кадри та й
оплат на неї кабінет і та й чоловік ви весь
у чат і на лижним членом та на землю мову
і даємо вузли весь готова those with us у
зовнішню насу слід оцінювати будь
ласка
красені
ми б кону йому закон проф ще свиту
перехідних положеннях тіла закону
казани bull и і створив і ютьб випередження
закон прийняті 2014 уроки терміни
переходу до напади нові системи вище
і розвинені я кар'єру цьому світитися
бакалавр магістр доктор філософії таким
чином молодший спеціаліст я кріс воду
години штучно бог перенесеної до системи
вище його свити
нас правді своїм законам же ви значен і
не я вишила свято а я хто який накласти
до професій на його почту та заростях
відома
ми процю йому треба редакцію нового закону
про правий і сильний світ молодший
фахівець буддою лежать ця вища
професіоналів вид і натомість помста астані
набер соромиться в 2016 уроки так само
як
та фахівця to much to win випадає їй
нові системи
бакалавр магістр та доктор філософії
людою acquisto буличова свиту
і гострий молодці дипломи мають рацію що про
свиту вид по видно так вже може ніби
spooky не тому що опера хіт них
положеннях закону вправо і що свиту
читку сказано що квіти плани будуть при
будуть визнавати і стояка дипломи про
вишитого кольору доступно забуто трошки
їжі на і що хотілося спільне туди ти у
нас всі уроку так перший води
вигляд booba те що експеримент у ступі
за зовнішнім з згодом до магістра туру
праворуч і про нього детальніше шайа разів
повис і normani на
susu не як у рояться і експеримент для
нас експеримент уже возив і ви і тому
що я де вдома ми за 1 процедуру їм
спільна з міністерством юстиції над
концепцію нове юридичне та 1
тс кладу в їх tejo юридичні почти
буду взуття оскол і кваліфікаційний
спить та мета експерименти до зубного boku
no es забезпечи typer візерунок ступу на
магістратуру а було завжди багатого
nascar щось злу жувати нападі до
магістратуру на томі
мета esp і так вже може бути пакла даний
потім я кісткового
до формування нової кваліфікації 2
випробував для наших допустивши правнуки
дякую за увагу